Benj ANCA there are a lot of video games
coming out right now it's very true yeah
all the time just things coming in from
left and right yeah and I think that
makes it really easy to miss a lot of
the smaller games that are still rad but
you know kind of get lost in all this
big triple-a and that's what we're here
to look at right now this is River City
girls hell yeah I'm so excited so for
those who don't know this is a sequel to
River City ransom yeah
would it leave the old beat them up the
old arcade beat them up
it's you're playing as the girlfriend so
in that game you played as these two
dudes and your girlfriend's get
kidnapped at the beginning and you got
to go rescue them so in this game you
are playing as the girlfriend and you
got to go save your boyfriend's now this
game is rad as hell yeah there's a style
everywhere we as you can see from just
the intro and these menus were going
through all right so I'm gonna play as
Socko I'm Kyoko 100% of the way all the
time
dude look at that loading screen or
they're just punching each other so
these manga panels even though they're
reading from left to right only got a
chance to play a little bit before we
did this but yeah I played a little bit
of packs before it came down and I most
like this game is rad and it's cool and
I think people should play this video
game yeah the uh I love I was actually
thinking I needed to beat him up like
just a little while ago and then they
dropped the announcement trailer for
this and it just felt like it was kind
of like a weird fate thing yeah I'm
having a great time it's specifically
great because I um I like you know that
Scott Pilgrim game that came out a
couple years ago that game was basically
an homage to River City ransom and you
can't play that game anymore which is a
real bummer so I feel like this is not
only a sequel to River City ransom but
sort of like a second Scott Pilgrim game
yeah yeah the way
all right no never our ground-attack yet
so you unlock more attacks as you level
up and you can spend money on special
moves so like you'll be able to do a
whole bunch of other just you pick
people up and throw them there's a whole
bunch of good references oh yeah
also in a weird thing I didn't like I
didn't see any of this leading up to the
game's launch but almost every character
is voice acted by like a YouTube
influencer oh I don't know that's like
Erin Hansen is the voice of like it's
either Jimmy or the double dragon people
oh okay it's it's both of the it's Erin
and what's his toes Danny yeah yeah
and then the oh you got you can recruit
people too which is yeah yeah yeah I
need a I should probably not beat them
up so we can do that it's all good later
I notice there were some locked doors it
looks like there's reasons to maybe redo
levels yeah you you do end up coming
back to areas once you get new abilities
and new info where I actually got to in
the game I'm actually back in the school
now okay after I talked to jacksepticeye
he told me I won't give the info unless
you give me a hamburger and then I got
him the hamburger and he's like ah go
back to the school and talk to the chef
excellent I love this so that's kind of
where things have been for me I just
think we've got to go downstairs great
she can pick up weapons and stuff it's
good times one thing I love is the
little detail whereas your characters
talk their portraits at the top kind of
like they sort of like lean over and are
like talking to each other there's like
a lot of good attention to detail on
this game yeah and it's also got some
real real certified bangers here I got
this alright so now I've got him as an
assist and each enemy has a different
type of assist it's like I recruited
like a police officer that would like
throw a grenade Oh
a cheerleader that did like a tornado
kick
oh yeah so this guy throws dust in
people's faces which is like a free
that's pretty good free Sun blocked
color a weird name oh you know them I'd
be nice if we could get that Scott
Pilgrim game back - oh I know that this
is this is a good stand-in does it stand
in this is very I this is the art style
so expressive the music's really good
music some fangers oh I totally stole it
from you you could have grabbed them and
all right it's okay
Oh Graham stop you might have that I
think I do yeah oh I'm the level two
I've been doing all the beating up I
stole it from you and I got the love
yang dude oh we got cool people to talk
to you all the time they go all out you
got like the pixel art style you got
these like character portraits you got
the manga cutscenes there's some
animated stuff later on yeah yeah
they're just throwing everything at the
wall and it it all looks really good
well we'll see the the animated stuff I
think during the boss intro cuz I think
we're gonna play up til the first boss
you want to go to crazy
oh no they're talking about our
boyfriends
sorry girls haven't seen them but we'll
lick so let you know the second we do
right mommy I don't like it
Thanks we gotta go beat up more people
now hell yeah I feel like they're the
villains like they're gonna be the final
boss I mean it's possible go get some
food that's good I'm head down here yeah
get my stomp on yeah the the progression
of like getting new abilities so you
feel like you're actually getting
everything you need to fight like more
effectively is kinda great yeah yeah
it's been a while since I played like a
good good beat him up yeah same
personally there are a couple of really
good ones on Steam that came out
recently they've been kind of holding me
over but between this and uh Streets
rage for I got a comeback heck yeah more
beat-em-ups police also talking about
puberty which is punching bricks until
they break away oh you can jump off the
walls tons of opportunities for cool
combo things might be able to play a
little bit past the boss so I didn't
realize we're going as fast as we were
[Music]
it is cool to that it's worth playing
through its both characters because
they've got very different move sets you
gotta level them up individually I
assume yeah like a cow so Craster at
Castle Crashers situation eventually I
know Kyoko learns a move that's
literally just like a hard strike like
dab and we did about that and that like
real okay it's it's everything I want in
a video game
excellent toss that guy back there only
he got these these vocal tracks that
come in it's pretty good I was not
expecting it the music's done by like
it's there's like seven or eight there's
a whole bunch of people who did the the
soundtrack basically the one that I got
really excited about was chip sille who
did super hexagon oh my god I was just
thinking about so yeah it's gone the
other day that's so weird so they did
some of the the music in this excited
for that fantastic oh that's all yeah so
I think he doesn't kick bust this thing
up there we go you can't go in there yet
so he I go back this way I'll grab that
baseball that looks like lighthouse
egami he does actually oh you know
there's a whole bunch of references to
stuff oh i sure
oh we don't even have a special move yet
but we get to we get those later on I'm
from a store oh yeah oh that was a good
kick got that level up again and I can I
can hop off of people's head you leveled
up three times that I'm holding level
Dubois Oh No Friendly Fires on I didn't
know I think we turned it off oh it is
on
oh no I hang you you killed you you
killed me oh this is excellent we can do
this really uh grabby there we go
you say kick you back in your pot he
kicked me back to life ah I didn't know
that was the things games awesome I love
it you can turn friendly-fire off by the
way I've done is I thought it was but I
guess we were right there oh wow that's
fine
[Music]
keep solving I beat him up there now you
got yours yeah stop them see once you
get that stomp although all the
possibilities start opening up I can
attack on the ground I can move around
pretty soon you'd be able to pick people
up off of the ground and throw them use
them as a weapon
oh he came to save her or no that was my
assist I was like why can't I do
anything what is this oh I lost my
assist Oh cuz I tied dad would do it
Oh still trying to get us she'll stop
them who could it be
it will definitely will play pass pass
this sure yeah we can we can play a
little bit the second level after yeah
why not
that's what I'm talking about anime heck
yeah it's kind of like a bobo type of
energy going on although i think a bobo
was actually in this game oh really yeah
no way easy to hurt it's part of the
school defence force it's my job to keep
idiots like you from sneaking out of
class you don't even go into school I'm
trying to earn extra money trying to get
some money like you're smarter than me
I've been in high school for seven years
oh yeah that checks out yeah I don't
care how big or how dumb you are
we're getting out of this school right
now you know what we got his name Kony
oh and Ricky Kyoko is definitely my
favorite of the two but I'm down with
both of them
I like moussaka I was like real like bad
energy oh yeah it's good real good
just watching some of the attacks you
were doing it looks like you're doing
like head butts and stuff yeah she's
just a very angry girl
she's a ground slam by the way for that
now my leg made moves like a headbutt
oh no I shouldn't went in what was I
thinking
[Music]
[Music]
do it I dare you try it
I got side steps I gotta be careful I
might die don't do it oh oh no that was
it that got me you'll have to come save
me to beat my soul back in I'll shoot
for the kick it's all good you do that
too meanwhile I wish I could run over
there
descending to have this oh geez nice
I'll make it fight you again got a real
mouth on you must be what Kunio likes
you
I'll be seen kunio and Riki yeah but not
around here I saw them both in crosstown
yesterday talking to someone creepy
looking creepy looking it's got to be
jacksepticeye this is characters creepy
it's not like okay I thought your whole
thing is like I watch people and that's
how I know the information get me the
hamburger I'll help ya we'll meet in a
second I realized as I said it I'm like
no no no hold on I know his character he
plays is creepy okay sorry if you're
punching you so much
[Music]
oh I started a - as soon as I couldn't
realize I still couldn't - okay thank
you
oh I got rejoined coming back in back in
oh I got my volleyball saved dude oh man
I'm behind
[Music]
the cool thing about this is this is
kind of like uh like an open world kind
of setup yeah so we got like this map
I'm gonna go equip that equipment we got
we got uh there we go some equipment
move move lists can look at all the
people you've collected get some some
background lore on them oh nice look at
your stats also I like how we have
different different phones and it's
they're entirely based of character are
you playing in Russian I was looking at
the options okay oh you can you can
return friendly fire on and off any time
if you want so that's good to know
you got move lists cool do this games
got a lot to it yeah I'm excited to dig
like deeper into it and see what what we
can kind of like but yeah I like it a
lot
I match it's not a terribly long
experience it's about thirty bucks yeah
which I I don't know like I'm already
just so sold on this game's art style
that I think it is well worth it I would
give it already recommend big shame okay
let's uh let's head down head down this
way all right so that's cuz it's like an
open world set up at this point people
just like constantly spawn in oh I see
so you gotta kind of like fight your way
through it I guess and this way oh I
thought I was hoping I realized poppy
with not what I was doing
dang
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Lupin Kings here took its armor King now
can't believe it can we recruit him yes
almost I'm pretty sure every NPC can be
recruited in or every like rant or
regular like person you can beat up
that's not like a boss go for it yeah
yeah still locked in we go there we go
yeah people just kind of hanging out so
there is jacksepticeye beating
jacksepticeye like it's in her and then
actually you'll actually see a Aaron up
here as well yeah like he's not even
like he voice acts characters but he's
also physically in the game as himself
we heard I didn't know I didn't know
about all that
yeah what do you want go die I've been
watching YouTube for Ricky and cuneo
right well I keep tabs on everyone
everyone what I will soon in the
meantime you help me get me a hamburger
you want first starters I'm pretty
hungry
go get me a double-murder Ferger oh okay
you were kidding no I'm yeah it sounds
like something I may I meet up but
exactly bring me a double burger and you
will be handsomely rewarded Milady's is
a girl's boy send like if you go over
here just kind of hanging oh yeah Ashley
Aaron just sitting there doodling well
dude I think that's a good place to call
this is the River City girls yeah as we
said like a lot of good games coming out
right now you know you got your
Borderlands you get your Gears of War
yeah but hey this game is really cool
and we
you should not pass up on it if you like
what you see right here yeah definitely
give it a look
give it a try if you can't get it right
now but you can get it done later just
remember it cuz yeah I think this game
is really cool I think it is worth
checking out
big same if for all your cool beat them
up stuff that you want want to see you
should definitely keep coming to
GameSpot cuz I won't play more beat'em
ups becoming more beat em ups